non honnêtement je me demande même
comment je fais encore en vie mais
ça fait vous avez suivi toutes ces
histoires en 2018 et en fait ça s'est
jamais arrêté
ça s'est jamais arrêté parce que je suis
condamné en fait à perpétuité sur les
réseaux sociaux pour toutes ces
calomnies c'est vrai que cette histoire
du jeremstargate à l'époque a énormément
fait parler
spectateurs
donc non ça va pas mieux et c'est
terrible parce qu'en fait on ce sont des
choses qui qui sortent en fait même des
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui et qui se
répercutent dans la vraie vie puisque
actuellement il y a plusieurs enquêtes
pour menaces de crime à mon encontre
matérialisé par écrit j'ai dû annuler
des dates de mon one-man show parce
qu'il y avait des menaces d'attentat sur
ma tournée j'ai encore reçu ce truc il y
a trois jours avec des menaces de mort
je me fais retenir en otage dans Paris
par un djihadiste qui est persuadé que
je suis pédophile enfin c'est invivable
en fait c'est invivable et la rumeur tu
[Musique]
après voilà alors
le livre démarre par des mots très durs
le livre que vous tenez dans les mains
et ceux qui me maintient en vie l'objet
grâce auquel je ne vais pas me suicider
quand d'autres l'ont fait et ne peuvent
plus parler
ce livre il est très important
tu as une élite et une lettre de menace
que tu as reçu récemment c'est une
lettre que tu as jamais fiches est-ce
que tu peux nous la lire cette lettre
donc alors ça c'est après avoir reçu des
seringues ensanglantées dans ma boîte
aux lettres donc je donc voilà petit
[__] on va te retrouver te buter ordures
fais attention à toi partout sale merde
on te lâchera pas on a vu sur internet
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est dit sur
toi on sait que c'est vrai
cache-toi il vaut mieux pour ta sécurité
pédée va crever et disparaît à tout
jamais
voilà donc j'ai beau envoyer ça au juge
d'instruction voilà leur montrer ce qui
se passe en fait je pense qu'il faut que
je me suicide pour que
les choses avancent pas ça il y a une
influenceuse là qui s'est donné la mort
et que je suis toujours très ému quand
je parle d'elle elle s'appelait ma vache
ou c'était une maman elle était accusée
de choses horribles elle n'a pas
supporté en fait la lenteur judiciaire
elle s'est suicidée étrangement tous
s'est accéléré quand elle est morte donc
en fait oui c'est ce que je dis à chaque
fois dans les tribunaux il faut se
[__] en l'air pour que les choses
bougent parce que personne n'en a rien à
[__] va leur donner raison en faisant
ça je sais et dieu merci j'ai peur de la
mort et je ne me suiciderai pas c'est
bien la seule chose qui voilà mais vous
voyez j'ai jamais vu des choses qui
allaient aussi vite que quand une
personne n'est plus là c'est quand même
dingue donc aujourd'hui oui je suis un
survivant parce que j'aurais pu me
flinguer 50 fois je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte quand même la
violence on vous traite enfin cette
histoire de 2018
est-ce que tu peux expliquer
téléspectateurs voilà parce que même moi
c'est vrai que tu veux que j'utilise la
vérité mais moi je m'en souviens même
plus de cette histoire donc je sais même
plus que c'était que cette histoire je
sais qu'on en avait parlé même ici mais
je ne me souviens même plus de cette
affaire est-ce que tu peux nous rappeler
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors en fait
c'est une histoire qui est très
représentative un de ce qu'on vit de nos
jours c'est une histoire en fait de
quelqu'un que je ne connaissais ni
d'avenir d'Adam un blogueur du nom
d'Aquaba qui s'est mis à balancer tout
et n'importe quoi sur moi pour pour
exister et donc vous savez comment vont
les réseaux sociaux ça va très vite on
est dans l'air c'est plus balance ton
peur c'est balance tout et n'importe
quoi sur n'importe qui pour exister donc
en fait c'est parti sur des accusations
absolument horribles vous étiez potes ou
pas du tout non pas du tout pas du tout
je ne le connaissais même pas donc je me
suis retrouvé du jour au lendemain avoir
ma gueule avec des noms gravissimes et
vas-y que j'étais complice de viol et
que j'étais pédophiles et compagnie donc
après bah ça s'emballe ça va très vite
sur les réseaux
un gamin était manipulé par un par un
paparazzi pour déposer plainte contre
moi alors que je ne l'avais jamais vu il
a ensuite retiré sa plainte en avant
avoir menti et ce qui est très drôle
d'ailleurs c'est que récemment j'étais
au tribunal il est lui-même actuellement
en détention provisoire pour agression
sexuelle bref donc je me suis retrouvé
en fait voyez accusé de choses terribles
le gérer une target c'est ça en fait
c'est une histoire qui n'était pas la
mienne donc en fait il y a eu ce
blogueur donc qui qui met des infos sur
toi derrière il y a cette accusation il
faut s'accusation c'est ça et derrière
après c'est trop tard mais après et
après tu fais pas on parle beaucoup plus
des accusations que des des preuves de
d'innocence la mécanique judiciaire
infernale entre guillemets se met en
marche et à ce moment-là effectivement
quand il est confronté à des juges des
procureurs il explique le
cyber-harcèlement personne ne comprend
rien parce que c'est tout nouveau donc
il est totalement démuni et c'est vrai
que le livre est impressionnant pour ça
et moi ce que je vous dis c'est
continuer à être courageux parce que là
vous témoignez vraiment là c'est c'est
bouleversant ce que vous dites mais on a
besoin de ça parce que le
cyber-harcèlement frappe des gens
actuellement et vous vous en êtes un
rescapé il faut continuer à tém comme ça
moi ce que je voulais vous demander
c'est les réseaux sociaux ont failli
vous tuer
en même temps en même temps vous en avez
vécu est-ce que vous regrettez
finalement d'être vous-même un produit
des réseaux sociaux gérants alors ce que
je regrette c'est mon passé ça c'est
certain parce que j'ai moi-même
contribué à un système où je pouvais
participer à des vagues de harcèlement
envers certains candidats télé-réalité
j'y allais pas avec le dos de la
cuillère et j'ai été vraiment un vrai
connard par le passé je présente
vraiment très sincèrement mes excuses
aux gens que j'ai blessé à mes débuts et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui voilà d'avoir eu
cette ce pense pendant là de pour me
faire connaître me permet d'être
crédible je pense dans ma lutte contre
le cyber-harcèlement parce que j'ai été
des deux côtés par contre je ne souhaite
pas quitter les réseaux sociaux en fait
c'est terrible parce que je les adore
mais comme je les déteste si je faisais
pas ce métier de créateur de contenu et
que j'avais pas besoin des réseaux dans
ma communication pour mes spectacles
tout ça évidemment je les j'y serai pas
mais je pense que c'est pas j'entends
souvent si c'est si dur et si on est si
fragile alors on s'expose pas sur les
réseau c'est le prix à payer la justice
m'a dit ça mais oui mais il suffit
d'éteindre son téléphone mais enfin on
dit pas un gamin car je suis allé à
l'école arrête d'être scolarisé ou dans
un autre registre on dit pas une jeune
femme qui est violée arrête de porter le
mini-jupe ça n'est pas à moi de quitter
les réseaux sociaux c'est aux gens qui
s'y comportent mal d'en être interdit
reste évidemment et je survivrai
j'espère à tout ça j'ai réussi
est-ce que tu penses parce qu'il y a des
gens aussi qui disent je te dis voilà on
se dit tout ici qui dit ouais mais
jeremstar et c'est ce que tu viens de
dire tu as dit j'étais en vrai connard
et il lui aussi tu étais harceleur par
le passé et tu le regrettes ça tu te
considérais comme harceleur aussi par le
passé oui oui je je le regrette parce
que j'ai vraiment déclenché des vagues
envers des candidats de télé-réalité
voilà inventer des choses ou pas non
j'inventeais rien en fait c'est ça qui
est terrible c'est que aujourd'hui au
moins on me dit que j'ai harcelé des
gens alors effectivement je peux
comprendre qu'effectivement sans m'en
rendre compte j'ai pu procéder à des
vagues de harcèlement mais moi ça
restait quand même léger je traitait de
l'histoire de fesses que les candidats
vendaient eux-mêmes à la télé enfin
voilà alors oui je dénonçais des choses
graves dans ce système la prostitution
dans le milieu de la téléréalité les
pratiques scatophiles à Dubaï et
compagnie dont on a entendu parler
j'étais le premier album
c'est suite à ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
qu'on a tenté de me faire tomber c'est
après c'est révélations là parce que ça
a dérangé des sphères mafieuses mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que oui je regrette la
manière dont je me suis pris à mes
débuts et si c'était à refaire je le
ferais pas et je dis d'ailleurs un
message aux jeunes qui nous regarde
attention à ce que vous faites sur les
réseaux sociaux est-ce que vous partagez
à ce que vous relayez parce qu'on peut
très rapidement sans s'en rendre compte
prendre part voilà des campagnes de
harcèlement il faut avoir un
comportement responsable et moi j'ai été
victime de tout ça tout m'a explosé en
pleine tête tu as eu un succès
incroyable j'y arrive moi je voudrais
voir regarde avec tes on a fait une
petite compil de toi voilà et c'est vrai
que on te sentait hyper heureux on
sentait vraiment été un des symboles de
de voilà de de la raison aussi sur les
réseaux regarde
on a fait un petit montage
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas comment t'appeler ce qu'on
appelle mojito amine oui
toutes ces partenaires pour la première
fois de ta vie tu vas te faire fouetter
je t'ai donc vernis une confectionner un
joli petit collier un peu spécial à base
de rouleaux de PQ
Cu autour de la tête allez hop hop ça te
va tellement bien allez hop
vécu allez hop c'est la tradition elle
s'essuie le visage avec du PQ
j'en peux plus
qui aime ça tu étais heureux là ou pas
quand tu te revois là est-ce que tu j'ai
un peu
quand tu regardes tu dis c'est pas un
décalage ça c'est sûr que c'est plus moi
aujourd'hui je ne renie pas ce que j'ai
fait ça m'a fait connaître et j'ai très
vite compris qu'il fallait être dans
l'outrance pour se faire remarquer dieu
merci aujourd'hui j'ai des millions
d'abonnés grâce à ça et je peux passer
des beaux messages aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'il faut en retenir mais oui j'étais
quand même heureux à cette époque parce
que c'était pas le même la même époque
les réseaux sociaux il y a quatre cinq
ans n'étaient pas ce que c'est
aujourd'hui on pouvait dire beaucoup
plus de choses il y avait beaucoup moins
de polémiques donc voilà mais c'est sûr
que j'étais dans un personnage très
grossier très vulgaire et c'est ce qu'il
y a aussi conduit à ma chute puisque
j'étais une cible
favorite voilà donc je suis pas étonné
de ce qui m'est arrivé surtout quand on
monte comme ça rapidement évidemment
qu'à un moment donné on a le le retour
de bâton mais voilà on aurait pu
m'attaquer en fait sur tout et n'importe
quoi mais sur des trucs gravissimes des
accusations de viols qui sont bidons
surtout quand on connaît ma vie sexuelle
enfin franchement avant le cheval
quelqu'un voilà très honnêtement
c'est parti beaucoup trop loin et c'est
terrible c'est terrible moi je vois je
reçois des témoignages de gamins à
l'école qui se font harcelés que font
ces gosses s'ils n'ont pas l'argent ou
même d'autres âge vous savez combien ça
m'a coûté 5 ans après parce qu'il y a
encore des des procédures judiciaires en
cours
200000 euros parce que j'ai une dizaine
de procédures en fait entre les
magazines entre les les faux plaignants
les harceleurs les journalistes les j'en
suis à 200.000 euros de frais c'est bien
sûr de l'argent que je ne récupérerai
pas parce que on nous les rembourse pas
contrairement à ce qu'on croit la
justice est payante donc en fait oui il
faut être riche pour se défendre et même
quand j'obtiens des condamnations ce
journaliste par exemple qui était
condamné en première instance a de la
prison il y va pas parce que en France
quand on est condamné à moins de 2 ans
de prison on y va pas donc en fait j'ai
quoi j'ai un document qui m'a coûté
200000 balles juste pour mon ego
m'indiquant que oui on l'a reconnu
coupable mais moi j'ai perdu mes
spectacles j'ai perdu mon poste sur C8
par exemple à l'époque j'étais en parler
on va parler dans un instant ça aussi
judiciaire franchement réveillez-vous
les tribunaux c'est un vrai cri du cœur
en fait vous attendez quoi qui est
combien de morts la justice est larguer
n'y comprend rien la justice est trop
lente il faut éradiquer le problème au
moment où il démarre sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'un temps après j'ai eu
le temps de me flinguer 50 fois sans
déconner est-ce que tu as pété un plomb
au moment ou pas est-ce que tu t'es dit
c'est je suis une star jamais non jamais
jamais acheté d'articles de luxe ni
déménagé à Dubaï enfin j'aime ma vie
simple franchement
j'ai toujours été très terre là-dessus
parce que ça m'a pris des années pour
construire tout ce que j'ai construit
donc je me rends très bien compte des
choses et pas du tout j'ai jamais pété
les plombs on m'a fait péter les plombs
nuances avec toutes ces histoires mais
et alors j'ai un petit tu étais sur C8
sur C8 et c'est là qu'il y a eu voilà
c'est c'est
à se gérer comme on dit tu as été évincé
de l'émission comment s'est passé je me
rappelle je te dis la vérité je me
rappelle même plus bah comme
malheureusement beaucoup dans les médias
la présomption d'innocence est
compliquée parce que quand quelqu'un est
accusé même si c'est faux on préfère un
petit peu mettre en suspens la personne
et c'est vrai que oui ça a été tu
reviendras après quand ce sera calmé tu
as dit tu reviendras après quand ce sera
calmé oui on m'avait dit que je
reviendrai et puis bah voilà je suis
jamais revenu parce qu'en fait on
attendait que je sois blanchi mais
personne n'a jamais compris que je ne
ferai jamais blanchi parce que j'étais
poursuivi par personne la justice n'a
jamais poursuivi pour les accusations
puisque elles étaient bidons donc en
réalité il faut dire ce soir c'est que
tu as jamais été poursuivi j'ai jamais
été poursuivi donc du coup jamais
blanchi enfin c'est ça en fait le truc
et donc ça a été un cassage de carrière
j'ai perdu oui mon poste à la télévision
je vous rendais compte à l'époque
c'était dingue parce que je sortais de
ce milieu de télé-réalité j'avais réussi
à être l'un des rares quand même à voilà
à arriver en télé à faire des sujets
policiers de société j'étais hyper
heureux de sortir de mon bain et de
faire d'autres choses et du jour au
lendemain voilà je suis devenu une merde
quoi enfin on m'a jamais aimé non mais
voilà tout le monde vous tourne le dos
parce qu'on a la télé qu'on est
quelqu'un de bien que parce qu'on y est
plus on est de merde non mais tout le
monde
aux yeux des gens ce que je veux dire
c'est à dire en fait toutes les marques
ont arrêté de bosser avec moi parce que
tout le monde avait peur que ce soit
vrai donc en fait il y a des
conséquences c'est ça qui est très grave
ça c'est extrêmement grave parce que
derrière toutes les marques arrêtent
d'être avec toi tu es invité nulle part
tu es
attention c'est la justice qui prend ses
décisions pas les médias mais vous
comprenez aussi et je l'entends à ce que
vous dites bien évidemment mais on peut
comprendre évidemment que la chaîne à ce
moment-là se dise on va mettre en
suspend le temps de et éviter évidemment
le problème l'instruction le temps hein
j'ai jamais retrouvé
alors l'émission n'existe mon travail
c'est ce qui m'a réconforté je me suis
dit au moins tu vois tu veux faire les
animaux de la 8
et la solution alors c'est quoi on s'est
appelé hier au téléphone parce que c'est
vrai que le livre a l'air super mais 216
pages même cumulées en 44 ans j'en ai
pas lu de ça donc j'ai dit je vais
t'appeler et c'est vrai que tu m'as
raconté tout ça mais c'est quoi
aujourd'hui la solution alors puisque le
tu n'es tu n'es tu n'as pas été blanchi
puisqu'il y a pas de il y a rien contre
toi etc quelle est la solution pour que
tu sortes de de de
[Musique]
et les autres en fait il y a plus que ça
à faire parce que si moi ça ne m’a pas
tué alors il faudrait que ça tue le
moins de personnes possible c'est
surtout ça quoi aujourd'hui est-ce que
tu penses que tu veux tu peux tu peux
redevenir heureux
que tu peux reprendre une vie normale ou
bien tu penses que ça oui oui bien sûr
il y a des évidemment il y a des jours
avec des jours sans quand je reçois ce
genre de lettre de menaces de mort tu te
dis si c'est quand même dingue il y a
vraiment des gens qui écrivent ça et
puis est-ce qu'effectivement on va me
tomber dessus dans la rue voilà comme je
le racontais ces histoires où je suis
retenu en otage dans un parc par un
djihadiste on se dit mais c'est dingue
le mec est persuadé enfin donc c'est
vrai que c'est dangereux mais malgré
tout il y a toujours du positif et
j'essaye de transformer tout ça en
positif et de me dire ça a été horrible
et je peux pas rester indéfiniment dans
le négatif donc oui je vais être heureux
je le suis un petit peu à nouveau c'est
dur mais voilà je prends ça comme un
parcours de vie et je suis un survivant
et il est hors de question que je me
suicide et qu'on me tue une deuxième
fois tu as bien raison merci
[Applaudissements]